I am a big fan of the Rockefeller
outreach lab it's inspirational and
motivating I think it's important that
students are able to see people that
look like themselves who are doing
something that they might not have
originally considered was for that lab
out loud is bringing science to life and
all of the different things like tonight
was about failing better and learning to
deal with failure and learning how
failure is actually incredibly important
in the process of doing science when
people think that failure is a bad thing
they don't know that later in life
failure is actually going to lead them
to succeed it's something new
Rockefeller really presents a unique
opportunity for high school students to
participate in authentic science
research meaning they can come in and
work on problems or questions that don't
have answers yet just like a real
scientist web science is a really cool
subject and also the people who give
their presentations are extremely
relatable it is so important to have
outreach events like this one because
events like this really allow the
scientists to have interactions that
want to be scientists and I want to
learn failure is inevitable but it
doesn't make you dumb it just means that
you have to work even harder and build
up bluth billion from this experience I
know not to give up every time I fail
I'd love to keep on going I think it was
great it was a good balance between
listening and then doing which is a lot
of fun it's super important to support
something like this especially because
they are really doing a lot of work to
engage with students you wouldn't
ordinarily be able to meet a scientist
God told my friends to come because
these people here have real life
experiences and what the real situations
that we could completely relate to so
you'll learn some information about them
and how to change our own situations as
well I really liked it this is my first
time and I'll definitely be coming again
I would like to call my game because
today I learned a lot it's really a
great opportunity I think this has been
a really great experience for me
you
[Music]
you